the Joe Rogan experience did you watch
UFC Saturday night no I did not have no
time I was flying all over the place
yeah and I had to go to another show not
a fight show in the ward show there's
this guy that fought on the undercard
zabita
Mago med Cherie buff holy [ __ ] is this
guy how many times did you were here is
his name many I [ __ ] it up at the wins
every was they were saying just call him
zabita just sub eat and I'm like no no
no I can get it he's he's [ __ ]
phenomenal animal he's one of Mark
Henry's guys down New Jersey okay that's
good Mike from Dagestan ok yeah where
there's just something in the water over
there yeah they just yeah the train was
Barris right but this guy is tall and
skinny and he fought Kyle Bach niak and
this kid Carlebach niak like he was
shorter he had a hard time getting in on
them and a beat had more skill in terms
of more techniques and more things that
he could do but goddamn Bach niak is a
[ __ ] animal he is a savage cuz he was
there at every second of this fight
trying to win never gave up never quit
and then to the end of the fight the
very end of the fight in the third and
final round the last minute of the fight
he's pouring it on and he's got some
beat up against the cage he's screaming
at him he's got [ __ ] blood coming out
of his mouth he's chasing after him this
is the end of the fight was him standing
in front of this via
there's showing some highlights as all
highlights yeah yeah but the beat that
guy is [ __ ] talented like you what is
larger this I think he's undefeated
that's good he might have won loss maybe
early in his career I feel like he's 15
and know though I think see you can find
his record does it say oh oh this is the
end so the end of the fight and I'm
telling you Bach niak is getting his ass
kicked the whole fight never said look
at this at the end stand it right in
front of him hands down
[ __ ] teeing off Holloway the whole
crowd going crazy this is my favorite
part it ends the buzzer goes off and
look [ __ ] hugs yeah
around the ring and I'm telling you
there was not a person in the [ __ ]
Barclays center that was sitting down
everybody stood up and went crazy me too
I was standing up the only time during
the whole night I stood up and I was
clapping you have to oh you know if they
give it y'all this is there's nothing
cooler than that you know that's what
Holloway when he made that line you know
he drew the line yeah man and it became
a thing now 15100 love it how's my
memories you are so good
my is a beat look at try saying that
name look at that okay is a bead muggle
made bishop Edith
shut it off ready both shut off Michael
Machado pulls a [ __ ] ass well meet
Michael edge a very very talented and
Mark Henry's telling me about this kid a
long time ago and he was telling me he's
like he goes I got a world champion
because this guy's gonna be world
champion I was like wow and Mark Henry
tell you that yeah yeah
[Applause]